thank you
[Music]
what do you guys think you're looking at
uh flight was delayed okay because of
this
that's a broken wing I know what it is
oh is that a trash can
no you're right
you can spend on that I know what it is
we get it right do we win no yeah but
he's already right he said this is a
trash can oh wow
[Laughter]
so yeah but it was delayed yeah because
plastic bag what could be a trash can
experts or have no said
um right
um
they couldn't take off they couldn't
take off because they couldn't identify
what it was what was it I knew what it
was that tar that is a swarm of bees
yeah oh so the trash can is not a man it
you know what trash can there are very
few instances where a two one of these
can imitate a trash
and here we are wow
we are witnessing the Marvel yes of the
one and only time that humans could
mistake one for the other yeah
it's a very rare we're totally winning
yeah it's a very rare anomaly so it can
I put us at a deficit real early don't
be embarrassed it's gonna be on you can
you invite us to your place I want to
know what trash cans look like at the
Big House apparently
it's just a big
it definitely it's it's a thing that
happens trash cans from AliExpress yeah
but this is what stops everything right
here yeah yeah so I didn't know that
like you can't take off because of a
swarm of these really why not why don't
they just fly right off maybe because
people are just generally freaked yeah
and they just won't do it I don't know
what what like that interferes with
because they don't want to kill bees
yeah
and then here's another storm
cool
[Laughter]
they use smoke to get rid of bees don't
she doesn't use anything what kind of
smoke is it what's in this I don't know
does it make them relaxed or what does
it do that I think it's supposed to
extend them and relax them it just makes
them like some calm it's weird they're
hot boxing them yeah please is that what
they are they're shotgun in them yeah
but the bee lady doesn't use anything
she like every so often will wear a
helmet every so often yeah but most of
the time she just goes in be Pros don't
tend to have a whole lot of stuff
because there's no they're not giving
off the fear hormones yeah she has no
fear is that really a thing really well
because yeah don't you release like some
sort of thing when you're like nervous
or like scared like you know you smell
different yeah like bees respond to it
that way yeah because I I heard that
bees only respond if they feel like
they're being threatened or they could
sense so if you just like put a baby
next to a hive the baby will find
because it has no clue I don't know
about that
yeah because that baby wouldn't be
afraid of nothing I got a baby guy if
you need a Connect
like would you put your puppy next to
like a sweater
not the puppies I mean your kids away
right because they'll try to invite them
or pee on them or something that's what
these dude here's a video of the trash
can
but I'm wearing my sunglasses all the
time so I look like a blind guy you know
you know what's funny today I wore
myself on the way over here and I was
like I think I just look like a blind
guy
you have blind guy features all day hey
you know you should you should do that
and I bet you you get on the flight
first
what is it about wearing Shades that
like some people look cool and then
other people look blind I think I just
have a general sense of unawareness
you know is it like when people talk to
you you're like going like this yeah I
started looking up in the ceiling I just
can't help it I get uncomfortable with
icons like this
have you tried different shades have you
tried different shades maybe like it'll
have a different yeah usually I do you
gotta get ones that aren't stylish
because then you because you're blind
you didn't know that they weren't not
stylish yeah
[Laughter]
that's really funny I honestly think
that's correct though because I think a
lot of the glasses I wear look like like
uh one of my sunglasses I have it looks
like the dude from
was that Robin Hood Men in Tights
blinking remember
glasses yeah I wear those that's like a
three blind my style that's what that
sounds like
Leon wore those too oh Leon the
Professional yeah yeah yeah yeah lots of
cool people but he has the Hat he has
the French hat can we just please like
focus on his logic can said that if if
you really are blind you would have wax
sunglasses because you don't know
there's nuts stylists you're just
wearing goggles yeah it's true
and all I heard was your sunglasses are
whack so the guy at the store would go
oh you gotta get these man these are
some top sellers
I'll be like okay and you feel love
you're like they do feel cool
like I don't want to sound racist or
discriminatory but you do look blind
what if I just did this more that looks
blind yeah or try to look not blind
right now
[Laughter]
is that the hardest request you've ever
had
as you can
it's really bizarre though
you got a blind thing going it was it
was when I was driving on the way over
here people must be like that when I was
driving all the way over I looked at the
rear view and I saw myself and I was
like yeah I look like a blind guy dang
it it's the glasses it's the glasses
these glasses I leave here it's my other
glasses that I have but mine
but what if I did this
[Laughter]
one
jeez I'll look like I'll show you throw
guys bro let's see what I mean okay oh
you don't look blind I can see your eyes
yeah
you sly
[Laughter]
oh wow
they would block the blue light and
people you know they tried them on
Advantage they'd raid ball these are
great I love these years I'm just like
10 more productive look like you're
gonna teach me a snowboard oh cool
that's really
really like you're so cool that you like
don't even wear any of the gear except
for the glass I don't need a helmet I
just [__] yeah you don't even need a
snowboard yeah yeah
he looks like a really like
the music producer
[Applause]
that's you I look like hey does he look
blind yeah bro that guy is tight he you
know what's funny he doesn't look blind
yeah it's like the way that he carries
his head like he's like am I do I have
uh
relax your neck more and like kind of
hang your head do I have blind there
that's how you do it look it doesn't
look blind
yeah
why don't somebody go there he's not
playing
right there we're trying to find him
we're trying to find my Essence
where he looks again I gotta work on my
brand man
I see him going back home to his wife
and then he's like how was you know in
the news today oh yeah they keep making
fun of me they say oh let's belong
why'd you change your voice so much like
why did I come here
is when he's at home yeah but I don't
think he puts any bass in his voice when
he's at home
Whispering all the time you don't want
to piss your wife off
oh how was your day
and I'm covering my mouth I also what
was the finger on the table
I feel like his body everything would be
passive and then she does this thing
like well she'll like reach from my
shoulder and like try to comfort me like
foreign